[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا وسهلا بكم في هذه
الجوله الاسبوعيه عبر المجلات الحرب في
اوكرانيا تدخل هذا الشهر عامها الثالث وبو
تهتم كثيرا بهذا الخبر الذي تاخر في صادره
في صدره الاعلام والتغطيه الاعلاميه وتخصص
هذا الروبورتاج
الميداني
من المعركه من احدى جبهات المعركه على مس
صفر وهي ترمز الى هذا الجمود على الارض
بالتزامن تتساءل في غلافها عن نوايا بوتين
ان فاز بهذا بهذه الحرب وتقول ان بناء عن
تسريبات وثائق المانيه انه قد يتجه الى
الزحف نحو مناطق اوروبيه اخرى جنوب
ليتوانيا واقصى شمال بولندا وذلك ما تتخوف
منه هذه الدول غير ان هنا في فرنسا الباحث
امانويل تود اخرج مؤخرا كتابا يقول فيه
عنوانه يقول بان الغرب قد فشل في هذه
الحرب امام بوتين وبان موسكو لا تملك
القدرات الديموغرافيه للتوسع وان حربها في
اوكرانيا دفاعيه اذا في هذه المساله هناك
نقاش طويل عريض ذ ايكونوميست تتحدث عن
الحرب في اوكرانيا كساحه تجارب لانماط
الحرب الم مستقبليه من بين احدى خصائص هذه
الحرب هو الاستعانه بهذه الادوات القاتله
بشكل عشوائي وهي الدرونز اي المسيرات
التي تعد تكلفتها اقل وخسائرها حجم
وخسائرها اكبر هناك ايضا ما تتحدث عنه
تايم ماجازين في هذا الغلاف وهو
دخول ذكاء الاصطناعي على خط المعركه
وتتحدث عن مساهمه الذكاء
الاصطناعي في مساعده الطرف الضعيف مقابل
الطرف القوي داوود مقابل جالوت في الحديث
اذا في الاشاره الى اوكرانيا
حيث يبلور الذكاء الاصطناعي الاستراتيجيات
المتابعه من قبل وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه
بناء عن المعطيات التي يحللها على الارض
وذلك ايضا نموذج للصراعات والحروب المقبله
حرب اخرى ما زالت دائره الحرب في غزه تدخل
شهرها الخامس وسط منع الصحفيين ال من بقيه
دول العالم من الدخول الى غزه ومن تغطيه
هذه الحرب مجله
لاكروا خصصت الغلاف و وعددها او ملفا
كاملا لشهادات احمد الذي يتواصل مع المجله
عبر تطبيق واتساب ليوثق يوميات الدمار
الشامل في غزه الجوع الخراب
وهذا التنكيل بهؤلاء المدنيين عدد القتلى
تجاوز
27 الفا في ظل صمت مطبق و ماتش باغي ماتش
تتحدث عن صمت اخر حول تعرض الاسرائيليات
الى الاغتصاب على يد مقاتلي حماس خلال
هجمات السابع من اكتوبر و اجان اجم
جولدشتاين هي احدى الفتيات اللواتي كسرنا
جدار الصمت ووثقت لهذا الاغتصاب الممنهج
ضد بعض الاسرائيليات تقول
بعضهن حامل من الاغتصاب حماس تنفي هذه
الاتهامات فيما السلطات الاسرائيليه تقول
بانها تمتلك ادله ست ستقدمها على هذا
التنكيل بهؤلاء
النساء الاسرائيليات في ذويك دائما في
الحرب على غزه ولكن نتحدث الان عن الداخل
الاسرائيلي وعن السياسه الاسرائيليه
الصحفي الاسرائيلي ماريوس شاتنر يقول بان
احزاب اليمين المتطرف قد تدفع
ثمن اذا حلفها مع نتنياهو خلال الانخابات
التشريعيه المقبله وذلك للمفارق بينما
تتجه ال يعني الراي العام الاسرائيلي الى
اليمين والى اقصى اليمين بعد هذه الحرب في
ذويك هذه عاصفه التي تنذر بان تاخذ
المنطقه الى دوام
وهو المواجهه بين ايران وبين الولايات
المتحده التي قد تتسع رقعتها ذ نيويوركر
الامريكيه تتحدثوا عن مواجهه اخرى في
الولايات المتحده بين ترامب وبين هؤلاء
القضاه الذين سيبون في امر ان كان سيتعرض
للمسائله الجنائيه ام لا وذلك سينعكس على
ترشحه للانتخابات وتقول بان شبح بوش
محاكمه بوش والجور يعود من جديد
حيث المحكمه
العليا تجنح الى صالح الجمهوريين على حساب
الديمقراطيين في هذا ايضا تايم ماجازين
تكتب بان القضاء او العداله في الولايات
المتحده لا تجرؤ او تخاف من ان ترمي ترامب
خارج هذه الانتخاب بات لو فيغارو ماجازين
تتحدث عن بغداد بعد 20 عاما من سقوط صدام
حسين وتقول انها تولد من تحت الانقاض ومن
تحت الركام ولكنها تقول ايضا بان هذه
الولاده ولاده في الظاهر للجوهر في ظل
الفساد وتبييض الاموال والطائفيه التي
تنخر هذه المدينه شارل الثالث الملك
الملعون في اشاره الى اسطوره لغوا مودي
منبو فيليب لوبيل هنا في فرنسا شارل
الثالث الذي اصيب بالسرطان وفق باغي ماتش
التي تخصص عددا كاملا له وفي لوبس ربما
اللعنه قد لا تصمد طويلا امام العلم وهذا
ما هذه البشاره التي تبثها لوبس التي
تتحدث عن نمط جديد لتطوير لقاح ضد انواع
متعدده من السرطان كما كانت الحال لتطويل
لتطويل لتطوير لقاح ضد داء كورونا وبهذا
اعزائي المشاهدين
نطوي هذه المجلات قدمناها لحضراتكم
كالعاده من فرانس 24 الى اللقاء